Oscar how are you pretty good I'm so
excited I'm one of the super star wars
because I'm waiting for it at candidates
every day since it was announced 2012
this thing's coming back yeah me too
and I know that that's what I really
wanted to ask you is how much of a Star
Wars fan I know that you are and
obviously you know and we know that when
you were cast you lost your mind mm-hmm
do you catch up on all the other stuff
that's happened with poe dameron in the
outside rows I know those comic books
there are you know novels and stuff that
are based on his character do you go
into any that's you know more about him
I'll tell you it's actually pretty cool
because that didn't happen until I
started doing some interviews and it's
it's it's it's kind of one of the most
amazing things about this whole process
is how open not only JJ but Lucasfilm
has been about the creation of these
characters so I because of where I
happen to be born I was born in
Guatemala and when I brought him all his
biggest claims to fame is that Guatemala
is featured in the end of a new hope at
the medal ceremony that was filmed you
know when the when they take off at the
end I was home Endicott tomorrow so I
said how cool would it be if that's
where Poe was from you know he's a rebel
fighter that's where the rebel base is
why wouldn't he be that what's that
that's an incredible incredible idea and
so they heard that and that made it into
this comic book so it's the first time
that you know me figuring out my
character's backstory suddenly becomes
becomes a car book it becomes canon but
that's that's you know that that
actually signals quite a bit of trust as
well reason I bring up those comics in
the commerce of shattered Empire yeah
yeah his parents post parents or indeed
we find out who they are so the rumors
of whether or not Leia and honors those
are gone yeah we don't we do know Luke
gave them a forestry hmm
don't know if you have force powers my
friends I know you're not gonna tell me
don't know we don't know what is this
guy lore about I assumed he was gonna be
like the new Han Solo when they're kind
of you you've got a nice attitude and in
movies you can give it back to people
you you can be grumpy you could be happy
you have all these things that you can
do what's PO all about well he is first
and foremost he believes in the force
he believes fully in the force he's
completely committed to the resistance
obviously comes from a line of rebel
fighters he's eager to prove himself as
a hero as a leader he has a disdain for
authority he has a hard time being told
what to do
he's eager to throw himself into harm's
way and he has a pretty he's got a mouth
on him he's got a bit of a mouth on him
but but I think one of his biggest
journeys one of the big journeys of this
character is understanding what it
actually means to be heroic what it
means to actually be a leader and and
that's a that's an interesting arc
you